ومعنا من بون المختص في شؤون السياسيه
منصف سليمي اهلا وسهلا بك على فرانس 24
اذا المانيا وبعض ضغوط كثيره استسلمت
وقررت منحه اوكرانيا دبابات ليوبارد كيف
يمكن ان يكون ذلك
بعد التردد كبير وضغوط واسعه سواء داخل
المانيا حتى من داخل الاحتلال الحاكم
وكذلك من خلال حلفاء المانيا في اوروبا
بالخصوص القرار يقضي مبدئيا حسب المصادر
التي عفوا سربت الخبر وهي مصادر شديد
الوثوقيه او الوثوق تعلق الامر بمجال الدش
بيجل وانتفاؤه قناه الاخباريه انه سيتم
بالفعل همم الترخيص لتسليم يعني همم بضع
عشرات او ربما اربعه عشر على الاقل دبابه
اليوم بارد من صنف اثنين اه سته وهي دبابه
قتاليه وتعتبر مثل همم يعني دبابه ابرامز
من الجيل الحديث للدبابات يعني
الاعلى من حيث الاستخدام في حلف الناتو
كذلك فان القرار يشمل التاريخ لدول
اوروبيه تمتلك هذه الدبابه علما وانا بنود
البيع دائما تتضمن هكذا يعني همم بنود انه
سيسمح لهذه الدول مثل بولونيا بايضا
بتسليم وتزويد اوكرانيا بهذه الدبابه
القرار صحيح جاء بعد التردد ولكن كان قد
لما حائليه وزيره خارجيه المانيا وكذلك
وزير دفاعها بوليس بريوس في لقائه مع
ستوته امبارح امين عام حلف الناتو امس في
في برلين عندما قال ان يعني هنالك اشاره
والتشييع للدوله التي تمتلك دبابه
ليوبارد اثنين
بامكان فتح المجال للقوات الاوكرانيه
للتدرب عليها وكان ذلك اشاره واضحه على
المضيف في هذا الاتجاه الان همم جاهزيه تك
عدد النهائي والتفاصيله لكن من المهم
التوقف عند نقطه تزامن اعلان برلين
بالتزويده اوكرانيا بالدبابات مع اعلان
منتظر من واشنطن بشان ابرامز الامريكيه
بمعنى انه القرار جماعي وفيه تنسيق بين
الحلفاء وليس قرارا انفراديا من برلين متى
ستسلم هذه الدبابات وكيف ستكون اليه
التسليم من المانيا الى اوكرانيا هل سيتم
مباشره من المانيا الى اوكرانيا ام سترسل
عبر بولندا
بطبيعه الحال هنالك من الناحيه معلومات من
بعض الشركات التي تصنع هذه الدبابه وايضا
بالاعتبار للمخزون المتوفر لدى المانيا
فان جاهزين تسليم هذه الدبابات ربما بضع
اسابيع وليس على الفور لكن واحده من
معضلات القوات التحالف وقوات تحديدا
الاوكرانيه هي قضيه وصول امدادات العسكريه
والتي غالبا ما تستهدفها القوات الروسيه
ولذلك انا لا امتلك معلومه كيف سيتم
تسليمها ولكن بالتاكيد انا الذين يسهرون
على ذلك ساحرصون على سريه هذه العمليه نظر
لان هنالك عمليات امدادات سابقه تم
استهدافها من طرف القوات الروسيه حتى قبل
ان تصل الى كيف يعني وهي في طريقها سواء
عبر الحدود مع بولونيا او ربما حدود بلدان
اخرى سياسيا وفي الداخل الالماني كيف همم
سترى هذه الخطوه
قالوا انها يمكن ان تؤدي الى تزايد حده
التصعيد الحربي يعني المانيا تسلم دبابات
الولايات المتحده تسلم الدبابات لن يؤثر
هذا بشكل عام على الامن الاوربي وامن
المانيا بشكل خاص
بالاعتبارات الرئيسيه التي كان ياخذها
المستشار اولاف شودس منذ البدايه في في في
تصريحاته يقول ذلك ولكن المناخ العامه حتى
قبل ان يلقي خطابه امام او التصريحاته
اليوم امام البستان عدد كبير من السياسه
من همم التحالف لائتلاف الحكومي وكذلك من
المعارضه المسيحيه الديمقراطيه لم يترددوا
في الترحيب بالخطوه وقال زعيم المعارضه
همم
فريدريش مارس زعيم الحزب المسيح
الديمقراطي انه لو كان مستشار اتخذ نفس
القرار وربما حتى قبل هذا التاريخ
بالتاكيد ان الان طبعا باستثناء حزب
البديل الشعبي الذي رفض وقال انا ستؤدي
الى مزيد من تدهور الوضع مع روسيا همم
بالتاكيد ان تسليم الدبابات يوبارد
وابرامز هي مؤشر على تصاعد وتصعيد كبير في
الحرب لكن هنالك اشاره ان الاعداد ربما
تكون كبيره هذا مؤشر مؤشر ثاني انها ربما
بقدر ما يمكن ان تكون مؤشر على التصعيد
بقدر ما يمكن تكون نوع من الردع لروسيا
انها تتوقف عن ربما شن مزيد من الهجمات
واستهداف مئه التحتيه الروسيه
اذا انقطع الاتصال مع الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي منصف السليمي على كل اشكرك جزيلا
الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات على هذه
المداخله على الكادر